字幕: Neeta Bhansali
校正: Hiroko Kawano
高校生になって すぐのことです
私は１つ夢を持ちました
高校に入って
色々な中学校出身の人と出会って
私は これまで自分が繋がりがなかっただけで
自分の地元にはこんなに面白い人たちが
いるんだってことを発見して
そしたら もしかしたら
他の高校にも もっともっと
面白い人たちがいて
その人たちと一緒に 何かを作ったら
これはもう めっちゃ
楽しいんじゃないかって思って
そして２年越しに その夢が実現しました
私は 今年の夏に
プロデューサーとして
こんなイベントを開催しました
「超学校祭」です
これは 13校の高校 中学校
そして60人以上の中高生スタッフが
集まって作り上げた
ひとつの学校祭型イベントで
学校の垣根を超えて
私の地元の帯広広小路商店街で行いました
例えば こんな風に歌ったり踊ったり
ほかにも 部活動単位で
企画に参加してくれたり
中高生が自分の好きなことを
表現している姿を見て
私の夢が実現して すごく嬉しかったです
[（英語）広小路]
でもこの超学校祭の裏には
実は ものすごい沢山の失敗がありました
それはもう数え切れないほどの
私は これまでプロデューサーとして
超学校祭の中で運営に関わっていて
ミスが起こると いつもこう思っていました
「私がやりたいって言い出したんだから
私が全部なんとかしなきゃ
プロデューサーなんだから
責任取らなきゃ」って
そこに囚われてしまった私は
周りが全然見えていなくて
「あ この資料を作り忘れてた
やばい 作んないと」とか
「お店との連絡するの忘れちゃってた
やばい やらなきゃ」
「あ 超学校祭のパンフレット
150部頼もうとしてたのに
間違えて1500部頼んじゃった
バカ」みたいな
（笑）
そんな 冷静なら犯さないミスを何回も何回も
その度に反省するのに
私は周りが見えてないから
また同じことを繰り返してしまって
そうやって 独りで抱え込んで 抱え込んで
でも 超学校祭１週間前になって
私は 限界になっちゃたんです
そしてもう無理だと思って
初めて中高生の運営のみんなに
大きく声を挙げて 助けを求めました
「ごめん 私無理だった
ひとりじゃもうダメだ
できない 助けて」って
そしたら 運営のみんなが
「え そうだったの？
ごめん そんな大変な状況だなんて
分かんなかった」
「え 今から私これ 何できる？
どうしたらいい？」って言ってくれて
しかもそうなったら
運営じゃない友達まで手伝いに来てくれて
で 私はそれまで知らなかったですけど
実は運営の中に
めちゃくちゃ資料を作るのが
上手い子がいたり
他にも会計の仕事が
好きだよ 得意だよって人がいたり
そんな感じで 超学校祭３日前には
あれよあれよと イベント当日に向けて
形作られていきました
そして 2018年7月29日
私たちは無事 超学校祭を
開催することができました
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
で 後日振り返った時 分かったんです
なんで この超学校祭を
ゴールに導くことができたのか？
これまで 私はすごいプロデューサーに
なりたいって思ってました
ひとりで全部 何でもできちゃう
スーパーマンみたいな
でも違った
私 できないんです
やりたいってことはあっても
ひとりじゃ なんにもできなかった
でも 自分の弱い部分をさらけ出して
「もう無理だ」って言って初めて
超学校祭のメンバーと
同じ温度感になって 同じ熱量で
１つのプロジェクトを
作り上げることができたんです
そして 気が付きました
これって「両想いの法則」
なんじゃないかなって
両想いって 私の中では
そこにいる人たちが お互いに惹かれ合って
尊敬し合って 高め合って
そして支え合えるような
そんな間柄になることだと思っています
両想いのためには
想いが共有されていることが大切なんです
そんなプロジェクトメンバーが
生き生き動くための両想いの法則を
今日はみなさんにお伝えしたいなと思います
想いが共有されている状態の
両想いを作り出すために
法則はシンプルな３つです
１つ目 自分をよく知ること
２つ目 自分をさらけ出すこと
３つ目 相手をよく知ること
恋愛でもプロジェクトでも
両想いになるための鍵って
コミュニケーションなんです
[（英語）コミュニケーション]
１つ目の「自分をよく知る」ことでは
例えば 私が何が好きで 苦手で
得意で 嫌いで みたいな
そんな何となく曖昧な部分で
分かってそうで 分かってない所を
きちんと言葉にしておくこと
そして２つ目の「自分をさらけ出すこと」で
よく強みとかは最初にチームで
共有できたりもするんですけど
なかなか自分の弱みとか
恥ずかしいし 勇気が出ないし
言いにくい部分を言ってしまうこと
そして３つ目の「相手をよく知ること」の前に
この２つ目の
「自分がさらけ出すこと」がくるのは
例えば心理学で
「好意の返報性」って言葉があるように
先に自分の弱みをさらけ出してしまうことで
「私はあなたを信頼していますよ」
っていう証拠になるし
そしたら 相手も自分のことを
さらけ出してくれるようになるので
２つ目に「先に自分をさらけ出してしまう」
っていうことがポイントなんです
そんな風にこの両想いの法則を使えば
いつか「両想いのための道」
っていうものがあって
そこへ想いがだんだん繋がっていって
この３つの単純な法則を
繰り返していくことで
コミュニケーションが
深まっていくんじゃないかなと思います
両想いになるために
例えば 今は「一目惚れ」とか
最初に一瞬見て好きになっちゃたとかあるけど
でも結局そこから想いが繋がっていくのって
どんどんどんどん相手のことを
知って 惹かれ合って
そういうコミュニケーションのもとに
成り立っていることだと思うんです
そんな風に こんな両想いの法則を使って
是非みなさんにも
これから先に もし何か
やりたいことがあった時には
自分の想いを伝えて
相手のことよく知るっていうことを
やって欲しいなと思います
さて これからの私たちの人生
何かをやろうと思った時には
もちろん全ての想いが実ることはないし
両想いになるってことも
なかなか難しいかなと思います
でも そんな時にも
この両想いの法則を使って
これが みなさんの心と心を繋ぐ
キューピッドになれば良いなと思います
ありがとうございました
（拍手）